my opinion the most important piece of
research is coming out of the Antarctic
right now is understanding how different
species cope with the changing
environments the rapidly warming air the
increased amount of precipitation the
decreased amount of sea ice so there's
something special about the three or
four areas right in here that there's
always whales we're trying to measure
the underwater behavior and movements of
the whales get an estimate of their size
and we're trying to understand what
whales need to survive and the manna
food that they eat if you don't eat
enough you're not gonna reproduce if you
don't reproduce it's a very quick
process into your population not growing
these tags are basically like a
smartphone that record the angle of the
whale whether it's rolled over on its
side the heading of the whale the depth
and the speed of the whale and it does
that hundreds of times a second it also
records video which is awesome because
we can then sort of corroborate the
things that the sensors are telling us
with what we actually see the whale to
do it it's got to 720p cameras in there
we can get about nine hours of
continuous data and all of that package
together gives us a really precise
estimate of the health of the animals
down here tagged data UAV data combined
is gonna be opening new worlds really so
let's find some whales yeah let's do it
we're in Wilhelmina Bay one of the
locations that we've worked in for a
long time and we're gonna try and deploy
one of the video recording multi-sensor
tags on a humpback these animals move
over big distances very quickly they're
real pain to work with because they're
difficult to find do you guys want to
get the drone in the air it's fun to be
a bad spot
what's that there it is
oh nice yeah that's good when we're
approaching these whales it's definitely
a high-risk kind of situation if it's
flu and to zodiac you would flip us over
with that much you know trouble you
probably have five or six minutes in
that water at the most before
hypothermia would set in and it would be
game over
anywhere you can put it
will happen but the work is definitely
not over the suction cup tags archive
all the data on them so we have to
retrieve that tag to get anything back
these animals get as curious about us as
we do about that it's looking at you and
it's it's kind of wondering what you're
doing there and we're asking the same
kind of questions
Lars correct me if I'm wrong this is the
first ever flight in the Antarctic right
for this equipment yes that's correct
couldn't ask for more except for Lars
Tobias a couple of drinks